pas votre cas
cette histoire de mariage avec les
nantis n'est encore qu'une de des
excentricités
à l'impossible nul n'est tenu
alors je voudrais comprendre la décision
est prise et est entre avec nous non je
reste un moment un contrôle de
comptabilité et en scène du cercle en
tout de même trop diminué depuis la mort
de ton père
alors éric
l' affaire dont je t'ai parlé c'est pour
ce soir jacques berrier sortira dans
quelques instants du cercle normes pour
le paiement n'y a rien de plus facile
non il aura la recette de deux jours
dans une offre seulement attention eric
je veux qu'on ne retrouve le cadavre que
dans quelques mois un comme ça je fais
d'une pierre deux coups je te paye avec
le fric de la maison et puis tout le
monde croit guerrier s'est fait la malle
avec la caisse
arbres arrachés
si l'e3
ces scientifiques je te dis oui encore
laissé une bonne partie de tes bons du
trésor mais vos jeux mon cher jacques
puisque vous ne rentrez pas chez les -
service supposé ça la banque aux
passants
d'accord